honestly it's kind of surreal you guys I
can't believe it's been 20 years since
the first x-men maybe 20 years not
judging by Holly oh you're not so bad
yourself professor
and Tomic is making me think that I
should have dressed up a little bit more
[Music]
knock-knock
whoa so many stars is that one yeah was
that Ian McKellen Brian the cast and I
were all just reminiscing about the
movie that we were all in together I
hear ya you know I love that that movie
I hope it's okay if I join I figured we
were all in x-men together x-men oh yeah
always good seeing you Ron
I actually invited a few others hey guys
so many timelines it's like a recap
Knott's landing two professors won't go
what's happening it's just like the
x-men movies you know it doesn't matter
oh sorry I actually thought this was the
Game of Thrones reunion you know
Tyrion Lannister was in an x-men film
okay bye actually had a James Bond
reunion zooming down Oh God me too split
reunion Star Trek I love you Patrick
Stewart by everyone that fell apart
quickly booth this is you and me Logan I
guess huh you know you know what that
makes this a reunion for x-men origins
reunite yeah
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new Deadpool Wolverine
and x-men video also talked about what's
going on with the new versions of those
movies at Marvel Studios in the video -
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos will do
a new Amazon giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and let me
know which of those x-men actors you
want to come back in the new Marvel
movies that they're doing based on them
so if you have no idea what's going on
here this is them doing this funny
Marvel skit for charity just combining
the different cast of a couple different
x-men franchises as well as the Deadpool
franchise that Ryan Reynolds I'm not
sure which one of them actually
organized this usually Ryan Reynolds is
more data do funny stuff like this it's
rare to see other actors but a lot of
them have been way more active the last
couple of months because of what's been
going on with the virus but it all
starts out with Hugh Jackman's Wolverine
Patrick Stewart's Professor X Fong cos
Jean Grey and Halle Berry's storm
celebrating the 20th anniversary of the
first x-men movie in 2000 if you guys
didn't know Kevin Feige was actually a
producer on that movie this is a picture
of baby Kevin Feige back in 1999 on the
set of that movie while they were
filming he actually worked at Fox before
he ran Marvel Studios the way they have
Ian McKellen and this too makes it seem
like he's there but he has his
microphone and his webcam both turned
off like he doesn't want to participate
they joke about Halle Berry still being
smoking-hot despite it being 20 years
later and then there crashed by Ryan
Reynolds Deadpool after which Ian
McKellen promptly bails I guess because
in the reality of this skit he was
supposed to always have hated Ryan
Reynolds and Deadpool behind the scenes
then Ryan Reynolds Deadpool proceeds to
troll the entire original cast of the
x-men movies then when Hugh Jackman
tries to tell him about the reunion that
they were trying to have he pretends to
not have seen the first x-men movie like
yes that one movie that you were in I
totally love that what that movie was
then retro actively tries to insert
himself into those original x-men movies
because he was in the movie with x-men
in the title as Halle Berry correct some
x-men origins Wolverine this was a lot
of visual references and easter eggs for
both different versions of the x-men
characters the new x-men films and the
original ones with the x-jet the old
x-mansion then Ryan Reynolds invites the
newer x-men actors to crash the party
James McAvoy is Professor X and so
Turner's Jean Grae I love the look on
Patrick Stewart in font cos faces here
like she's kind of horrified like what
is happening here even Hugh Jackman
looks kind of disgusted with what's
going on just look at his face it's
hilarious
in reality though fomka for instance did
speak very kindly about the newer x-men
actors the premiere of x-men Dark
Phoenix a little while ago even though
that movie did terribly she was very
kind when speaking about sophie Turner
in real life so it's not like she hates
sophie Turner or her character or
anything like that and they did bring
her back for x-men Days of Future past
so there has been relatively semi recent
FACA coming back into the x-men
franchise so never say never that she
could ever come back in cameo again in
the future
Ryan Reynolds makes the same Deadpool
timelines joke from the first Deadpool
movie the joke about the Knott's landing
recap if you never watch that show it's
so old that I wasn't old enough to have
watched it when it originally aired but
it was a soap opera that ran for a long
time and had a lot of core cast changes
in recasting z' like the x-men movies
over the years James McAvoy makes it two
girls one cup joke using Professor X if
you don't know what that means please I
implore you do not go look it up it will
only cause you unimaginable pain then
when everyone starts getting confused
Ryan Reynolds takes another shot at the
x-men movies by saying that even though
what's happening now on screen with all
the crossovers and timelines is
confusing just like the x-men movies it
doesn't matter as if to say the x-men
movies don't matter anymore because
Marvel is going to reboot almost
everything again so if he turner makes a
game of thrones joke then Ryan Reynolds
makes a tyrion lanister joke because
Peter Dinklage played Bolivar Trask in
x-men Days of Future past
Halle Berry and vodka both make James
Bond jokes because they were both Bond
girls in different Pierce Brosnan era
James Bond movies vaanga is still one of
my favorite crazier Bond girls she was
awesome in Goldeneye then the rest of
the x-men actors slowly bail out for
their other franchises like Star Trek
leaving Hugh Jackman stuck with Ryan
Reynolds who calls him Logan then they
end with a big x-men origins Wolverine
reunion joke with Liev Schreiber's
Sabretooth crashing the party as they
all bail out simultaneously because none
of them want to be associated with that
movie
anymore Ryan Reynolds even had Deadpool
kill off that timeline version of
himself in the Deadpool to post-credit
scene the funny thing about Sabretooth
for everybody wondering what ended up
happening to his character is that
originally they intended on bringing him
back as old Sabretooth for the Logan
movie but wound up cutting that scene
out so they were only gonna bring him
back to then kill him off because they
were killing pretty much all the core
x-men during that movie but a really big
update on what's going on with Deadpool
3 and the new Marvel x-men films and
some of these older x-men actors coming
back for cameos and new Marvel films
recently Morena Baccarin who plays
Vanessa in the Deadpool films did a big
interview talking about Deadpool 3
people asking her are you coming back
for Deadpool 3 she says that she has not
been contacted mostly because they're
still writing the movie right now
but they are working on the movie so
there is a Deadpool 3 they intend on
releasing eventually she did say that
she expects to come back and just hoping
that her part is better than what they
did with her in Deadpool 2 just because
she was barely in that movie also
separately Ryan Reynolds recently did an
interview on Jimmy Fallon talking a lot
about what's going on with the future of
Deadpool in Marvel Studios I'll link the
video that I did about that at the end
of this - for the most part they are
going to let it be rated R but they're
just trying to decide how connected it's
going to be to the MCU because for the
most part the MCU films aren't going to
be r-rated so right now based on what
Ryan Reynolds has said it sounds like
the plan is for Deadpool 3 to just be
off by itself doing its own thing they
can reference anything that they want
from any of the Marvel movies it's just
a question of which Marvel characters
which MCU actors will show up in that
movie then eventually he will cross over
into a traditional MCU film but it'll be
more pg-13 version of that character so
think about the way that they did the
once upon a Deadpool is a pg-13 cut of
Deadpool - when Deadpool shows up in a
future Avengers film like Deadpool in
Avengers 5 that's how he would feel a
pg-13 it's a family movie also money
also Disney and as for some of these
other older x-men actors coming back
obviously I know everyone wants Hugh
Jackman to come back and cameo as
Wolverine I've already done a bunch of
videos about that he said that he's done
with the character after Logan but we
all know to Never Say Never so you know
who knows what's going to happen in the
future but right
now it sounds like there are no plans
for hugh jackman to come back in anyway
the other really cool Easter Egg to
behind the scenes is that Patrick
Stewart revealed that he had met with
Marvel and Kevin Feige awhile ago after
they got the rights back to those
characters about coming back and doing
future Marvel movies as his Professor X
character so it sounds like Kevin Feige
is trying to get some of these older
x-men actors to come back the way
Patrick Stewart explained it though was
kind of a very Hugh Jackman explanation
he said that because the meeting that he
had with Marvel about new Marvel movies
as Professor X happened after they had
finished the Logan movie and he was so
happy with what they did during the
Logan movie in his character that he
wasn't really jumping to come back but
also to with him never say never but in
terms of that new Marvel x-men reboot
movie in Deadpool 3 the plan right now
is for Marvel to release those during
Marvel phase 5 which because of the
delays that have happened this year
won't be before 2022 and could be as
late as 2023 in 2024 depending on what
happens next year Marvel hasn't formally
announced their big comic-con plans for
the movies so it sounds like there are a
bunch of trailers for them to drop but
they haven't said how they're going to
do that whatever they wind up doing I'll
do videos for all of it so no worries
leave all your requests in the comments
below and let me know which of these big
actors do you want to come back in cameo
as their original characters in new
Marvel projects while you wait for
everything click here for that other
Ryan Reynolds Deadpool 3 clip and click
here for that brand new boys season 2
trailer thank you so much for watching
everyone stays safe maximum effort
[Music]